Kim is with us Kim's in Maryland hi Kim
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up I just wanted to know what your
opinion was on giving your adult
children money
I have a daughter Hillary standing
before us and has two children and she's
asking me for money to get out of a an
apartment that she remembers and she was
purchasing at homee
she's purchasing a home and she wants
you to give her she want you to give her
money
whoa okay and do you have money
less than $200,000 in my 401 my house is
always paid off I was you know trying to
get that paid off so I don't have a lot
of debt but I'm mostly 60 years old so
so you're 61 thousand a 401 K your house
is almost paid off what do you make
twenty five thousand good for you and
you're single married okay that's your
household income my household is about
like that okay is that your household
wealth as well what do you mean well
does your husband have a 401 K in
addition to the two hundred you're
talking about he has one with very
little in it less than ten thousand okay
so your house your total nest egg for
your household is just a little over two
hundred with making but making two
hundred fifty thousand and sixty two
years old right okay all right I got you
and this daughter is his as well right
no no she's not okay no her dad when he
was two I got you okay
and so she's moving out of an apartment
and buying a home but she doesn't the
money to do it I don't know she has it
or not she makes sixty five thousand
dollars a year but she had the money she
would be accessing in in the family home
so she's fine another time I'm sorry say
that again her ex is staying in the
family home she's buying a smaller home
Oh
she's going through a divorce right okay
but she doesn't have any money obviously
because she's asking you for money no
okay and so what is her long-term plan
with money she gonna have an income
she's gonna support these kids the ex is
gonna support him with his child support
how are they gonna live well she has a
job making about $65,000 a year okay all
right okay
but I'm guessing that there's probably
some debt in that family that she's
going to end up responsible for a part
of it is that probably true
I would hope but not the case I got in
her yearbook years ago and I think that
they were pretty much out of debt
although she did ask me to pay off a
credit card a few months ago which I did
for a moment what was about $500 okay so
what I do what I want to do when I'm
helping someone especially people that
are that close and I love that much is
one of my own kids right is I want to
make sure that my help is not assisting
them in stepping into a bear trap I want
to help them that into a situation
that's sustainable that gives them a
bright future but I don't me
participating in the bad decisions that
they're making because they're hurting
is not help and I think that's what's
going on here this lady don't have any
money he's staying in the family house
it probably doesn't have any equity in
it does it
are you guessing yeah okay and so I make
sure the divorce decree if you can reads
that he has to refinance and get her
name off of that mortgage so that she
can get her a mortgage in a couple of
years when she gets straightened out she
does not need to buy a house right now
she's going through a divorce it's one
of the worst years of her life and she
has no money and this is not the time to
make a decision to buy a house she needs
to rent something she already had the
settlement date how much is the
settlement I don't know it's not getting
any information and I'm not giving her
any money I'm not giving her any money
apparently she's getting some money
December 2nd why does she
money from you I don't know that's not
right that helping someone when you've
got incomplete information that doesn't
need help and you're participating in
their crazy is not really helping you're
not really helping her I want to love
her well I want to love her with all my
heart on my being and I have to have the
whole picture to be able to know that
I'm helping otherwise I'm just throwing
money at stuff and if those kids need
some food will feed those kids if she
needs a thousand or two thousand dollars
or something to get set up an apartment
that's fine we'll help her get set up an
apartment but let's create her a future
life and not allow her to step up into a
house she can't afford buying a house
making a decision to buy a home in the
midst of all this emotion and heartbreak
is a really bad idea
but she's already gone through with it
she's already signed the contract
nothing to not do about it okay then she
I'm not loaning her money I'm not giving
I'm not loan her money period but I'm
not giving her any money okay she's
creating these traps where you have to
participate in her crazy with limited
information based on the fact she
painted herself in the corner and now
asking you to participate in that I'm
sorry I love her but I'm not gonna do
that
no you do what you want to do but I
wouldn't do it
I wouldn't loan her money ever I
wouldn't loan anybody money under any
circumstances but I certainly wouldn't
give her money in this situation because
you were not involved in the decision if
she wants your money you get to be
involved in the decision and so you know
I'm sorry Olivia and I'll be here for
you and I'll be your biggest cheerleader
and I'll help you but this is not this
I'm not gonna be able play this time
this this game is not a game out of like
the rules for and I don't want to play
in this game so I think you're gonna
give her money anyway but I wouldn't
thanks for the call